[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i hear that like you all know each other
right well first of all that was awkward
me acting and i got like one of the
greatest one of the guys i looked up to
when you're looking at me i was like yes
it was amazing
that's exactly what he did actually no
it was great and what a great scene too
that a lot of kids relate to and parents
will relate to as well sadly um
but do you all know each other yeah yeah
we uh i i got invited to do a little
workout with lara hammond you know eric
hamilton he's the 100-foot big wave
crazy surfer and he says uh hey i saw
him on the beach one time and he goes
hey come up and come work out with me so
i go to his house up in the mountains
you do that a lot y'all are just like
hey come work out that's all we do right
that's it that's it
that's what we do so glad i'm a woman
right now
but he's got this um he's got this pool
and it's custom made for these workouts
these underwater workouts with weights
and so i go up there and i jump in the
pool and and i see him coming out and
he's shredded and i'm like this is a
pretty cool little workout
uh and and i start to do the workout and
you're underwater you're panicking and
and you're you can't breathe you're oh
you're not like doing it in your head's
above water you're underwater no you're
under one and there laird you know he
serves 100 foot wait he's he's crazy
like he's like hey uh go do a workout
get underneath the water and then you
then you're going to go to the uh ice
cold tub with just filled with ice and
then you're good for you and then from
there you go to 180
degrees sauna and you do a bike for 20
minutes and i'm like i almost died i was
like what does your heart do during this
yeah
but he does it all the time
yeah but what's great is you like you
look at him and you go no like this
guy's going to show up and he's going to
control the whole pool and he got there
and he started crying and
one of the worst things i ever did in my
life i was like oh my gosh
you did great you did great oh my god
this reminds me one time they were like
my friends on a vacation like we're
gonna go on this beautiful hike and i
was like hell yeah let's do it it was
like fat camp from hell it was
it was i was i literally my stomach got
upset i was like oh my i was like it was
the worst experience of my life
and i'm don't that's why i don't work
out um so we're celebrating the 80s all
week so do you have a favorite 80s
memory uh well you know i was that's
when i grew up obviously i was born in
1976 so the 80s were my decade to make
who i am right now and so i spent more
watching movies and obviously i know you
guys talked about goonies yes uh but i
loved weird science weird science
lebron kelly lebron i was like were we
supposed to come out looking like that
yeah she's beautiful eddie murphy coming
to america
all those movies commando yes i loved uh
first blood with with uh sylvester
stallone rocky movies i love davies i
loved all those too yeah and this is bad
and this is back uh most kids that like
today i have four kids and they watch a
movie like one time and then they'll
never watch it again i mean hardly
unless it's like uh let it go or one of
those yeah you're talking about frozen
don't get me started just let it go let
it go that's like calling in kanto we
don't talk about bruno
that's amazing but back in the 80s we
watched the movies over and over and
over again i've seen goonies 300 times
oh yeah labyrinth david bowie david
whatever top gun i've seen that 87 times
yep
all those movies uh by the way fun fact
um
the uh uh chunk goonies
do you know where i'm going with this do
you know do you have any i don't either
the fact that he's a
lawyer now he's a lawyer now yeah he's a
lawyer now but he went to i went to
berkeley and i played football and
basketball there he was the yell leader
from the cheerleading school oh really
what so during the game oh man no it was
cool
i remember uh one time we're in the
middle of a game and both teams were
playing in the game i'm standing on the
side and the defense was on the field
and all of a sudden we hear the crowd
going crazy and i'm like there's nothing
happening on the field and i turn around
and i see chunk doing the truffle shop
he's got his shirt now
true story
no true story my brother who's a decade
older than me would make me do that to
get into our apartment he'd be on the
balcony and i'd have to do i was chunky
and and he'd make me do the trouble
shovel to get in i think it made me
funny in the end um
who's got the talk show now
yeah who's got the now in therapy
okay so your new show is called long
slow excel that is an interesting name
um so explain what it's about so it's uh
about a collegiate uh female basketball
team that just won the national
championship and then off of that
scandal rocks the whole university the
sex scandal there is uh the first couple
episodes came up came out already
there's a murder and then i play a
father with within the story i'm the
story within the story and that's where
i really loved being able to do this
because kind of tapping into that you
know being parents yeah working with my
daughter wanting the best from her but
she doesn't know why i have a little
secret i'm not gonna have to watch the
show but there's a reason why i'm so
hard on her and why i'm i was gonna say
you kind of seem like a hard ass yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah then i have to my mom was
and i turned out fine look at you once
again in therapy but everything's fine
um
just kidding i love you mommy um we need
another commercial break everybody
tony's new show long slow xl is on
spectrum now be sure to check it out
[Music]
you